hey what about guys my name is the Chano
and welcome back to my state plus plus
series alright this is weird I mean like
some check hotel just don't ask
questions so today we're going to be
talking about what static means inside a
class or a struct last time we talked
about the static keyword in C++ and what
its meaning was if it was outside of a
class or a struct and there's a link to
that video in the description below as
well as a card on screen so go ahead and
watch that but today what a static mean
if it is inside a class or extract in
pretty much all object-oriented
languages static inside a class means a
certain sense if you use it with a
variable it means that there is only
going to be one instance of that
variable across all instances of the
class so if I make a class called entity
and I keep making entity instances I'm
still only going to have one version of
that variable meaning if one of the
instances changes one of the variable
meaning if one of those instances
changes my static variable it's going to
reflect that change across all instances
because really there's only one variable
even though I've made a whole bunch of
class instances and so because of that
there's no point of referring to the
variable through a class instance
because there's like there's like a
global instance for that class with
static methods you get a similar effect
where you just you don't have access to
the class instance a static method can
be called without a class instance and
inside a static method you cannot write
code which refers to a class instance
since you don't have that class instance
to refer to let's jump in and take a
look at some examples so over here I'm
going to write a struct called entity
and I'm going to give it two integers X
and y note that I'm using a struct here
but you could use a class it doesn't
matter the reason I've chosen a struct
here is because I want those x and y
variables to be public and by using a
struct they're going to be public by
default I've made a video about the
differences between with classes and
structs as well if you haven't seen that
there's a link everywhere check it out
so right now we have a pretty
straightforward empty class we can
instantiate it like so set the values to
what we want them to be such as 2 & 3
and we're ready to roll if I want to
make another instance of that class I
can also do that this time I'll
initialize it using an initializer so
we'll set it to like 5 & 8 for example
and also let's give our entity struct
some kind
of function so that we can print what we
have to the console just using standard
C out and there we go so if I come down
here and I print E and E one the
behavior here is going to be fairly
normal and what you would expect so we
should get two three and then five a for
our second one and you can see that's
what we get however things will change
if I make the variable static so if I
come over here and I make these x and y
static first of all my initializer here
will fail because x and y and no longer
class members so we can forget about
that and rewrite our code to be this
which again is not strictly written
correctly however for an example it will
work to make sure we're referring to e1
here so you can see we are referring to
two different instances or it appears to
be so at least if we run this code we're
going to get unresolved external symbols
because we actually have to define those
static variables somewhere and we can do
so over here by just writing int entity
which is the scope of this static
variable then the name of the variable
and we don't really need to set them
equal to anything if we don't want to we
can just write this so now they've been
defined the Lincolnton linked to the
appropriate variable and we can run our
code however if we do so you'll see that
we actually get five eight five eight
printing twice which is a little bit
weird you can see here in our code that
it clearly appears that we're setting x
and y to two and three for the first
instance but then five and eight to the
second one however remember that those x
and y variables when we made them static
we made it so that there was only one
instance of those two variables across
all instances of our entity classes
which means that when I'm changing the
second entity's X&Y they're actually the
exact same as the first one they're
pointing to the same memory picture two
different entity instances however the x
and y does they're pointing to a shared
they're pointing to the same x and y and
as such there's no point in us referring
to them like this we can actually just
refer to them like this as if they were
inside the entity scope because really
that all they are it's like we've made
two variables that are inside a
namespace called
entity they don't really belong to the
class they do of course in the sense
that they can be private and public and
they have like so they are still kind of
part of a class and not just a namespace
but for all intents and services they
basically are just in a namespace and
they have nothing to do with any kind of
allocation when you create a new class
instance or anything like that so if we
were to rewrite our code correctly you
can see this makes a lot more sense now
why we're getting 5/8 everywhere because
we are actually modifying the exact same
variable this is of course really useful
when you want to have variables across
classes you could of course just create
a global variable or instead of a global
variable it could be like a static
global variable right so it's still
internally linked and all that stuff
it's not going to be global across your
entire program however doing that would
have the same effect of this so why
would you do this the answer is
basically just it makes sense to put it
inside entity if you have something if
you have a piece of information a piece
of data that you want to be shared
across all entity instances or it makes
sense to actually store it inside the
entity class because it's to do with
entities for organizational purposes
you're much better making a static
variable inside this class rather than
having some statical global floating
around somewhere static methods works in
a similar way if I make this print
method ecstatic then it's going to work
fine because you can see it's referring
to x and y which are also static
variables I no longer have to call it
like this I can also call it like so in
fact this would be the correct way to
call it and of course you can also
notice that it's clearly going to be
printing the same thing because we're
running the same exact method twice and
in this particular example we don't even
need class instances at all because
everything we're doing is static however
things would break here if we decided to
make x and y non-static would keep our
print method as static because static
methods cannot access non static
variables and there's a very very simple
reason to that sometimes we get a little
bit confused as to what static scene can
access what a non-static thing it's
really not confusing at all check this
out I'm going to bring back my entity
instances and rewrite my code so that we
actually do have a separate X and Y for
each instance of the entity class I'm
going to still leave this print method
as static I'm going to get rid of this
definite
laughs static variables and get rid of
static in front of X&Y if we were to try
and compile this turn now we're going to
get an error and you can see our error
rates illegal reference to non-static
member entity X because you cannot
access this from a static method the
reason is that a static method does not
have a class instance I might go a
little bit more into how classes
actually work in a future video but
essentially every method that you write
inside a class every non-static method
always gets an instance of the current
class as a parameter that's how classes
actually work behind the scenes there's
no such thing as a class they're just
functions with a hidden parameter of
sorts a static method does not get at
that hidden parameter a static method is
the same as if you wrote a method
outside of the class if I were to write
a print method outside here suddenly
this probably makes a lot more sense as
to why you can't access X and why
because you don't know what they are now
picture that you have this exact same
method however an entity actually was
passed in as a parameter and your code
was converted to this suddenly this
works what we've just written here this
method that we've just written here is
essentially what a class method that is
non-static actually looks like when it's
compiled and so if we take away this
instance which is exactly what we're
doing when we add this static keyword to
a class method we get errors that's why
you're getting errors it doesn't know
which entities x and y you want to
access because you haven't given it a
reference to an entity so hopefully that
makes a lot of sense and that clears
everything up next time we're going to
take a look at integrating this new
sound static knowledge into our low
class that we've been working on so you
guys want to see what that looks like
you can look at the how to write a C++
class video as we go along with this
series we're going to keep adding to
that low class and figure out some new
things we can do and kind of keep
improving it as we learn new concepts
static is incredibly useful for static
data data that doesn't change between
class instances but that we actually
want to use in our classes thank you
guys for watching as always you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram links
in the description below and if you
really like the series you can support
on patreon.com for such the Cherno thank
you
everyone who's supporting this and
making this possible love you guys I'll
see you next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]